one benefit of finding the most
intelligent civilization in the Milky
Way because we can ask them questions my
first question would be what was there
before the Big Bang the second question
is where is the nearest Interstellar bar
where extraterrestrials come together
and have conversations we know from our
personal experience that finding a
partner gives a meaning to your
existence so if we ever find a partner
out there it could give a meaning to our
existence the universe will not appear
to be pointless anymore a we've seen uh
you know tremendous interest in your
book and that's been phenomenal and I
wonder what the reaction to the book has
been uh since we last spoke back in I
guess it was September late August and I
want to get uh your take on just the the
popular reaction to your second book
after coming as it did on the heels of
your phenomenal uh runaway Smash Head
bestseller exra terrestrial so tell us
please AI how has been the reaction both
uh in critical circles and in the
consumer circles and then we'll move on
to uh to some some matters that are
pressing because they involve a critique
as is natural in science to get a
critique maybe not the way it was done
but we'll get into that so please tell
us AI how has been the reaction to the
new book the first book extraterrestrial
became a bestseller in many countries 28
editions 25 languages uh and that
attracted a lot of attention I had of
the order of actually more than 3,000
interviews as a result of that just over
the past couple of months there were
three profiles uh one in the New York
Times magazine another one in uh the
Telegraph and the last one was in the
guardian uh and um you know there is a
lot of attention there is a documentary
being prepared um about my research by
Netflix and they have been filming for
uh more than a year and in fact they
were following me when I went to the
Swiss
Alps last week and uh They Carried the
camera all the way up and that was quite
tedious for them uh and then they went
with me to Washington DC as well and
just yesterday uh so there they they
keep following me there are lots of
interesting things happening and um you
would see them hopefully when it comes
the documentary comes out hopefully in
2025 um lots of things uh then as I
mentioned there is a play um that was
presented at my home about the research
it includes a song that was composed by
Alan Bergman who won many awards
and uh wrote yentel for uh Barbara stron
and uh and then in addition there is a
sculpture being made about inspired by
my research by an artist in Spain and so
lots of things are happening um you know
it very often happens that I go places
and someone comes to me and asks for a
selfie which is something I'm not used
to uh it happened even on uh Richard
Branson's Neer Island when I was there
as the
Entertainer of a group of 40 people with
a a net worth each of them a net worth
above uh $400 million and one of them
came to me and said can I on the high
side of that you were on the higher side
of that brought the average up you
brought it up a little bit no I'm at
zero in that scale uh but uh one of them
came and said can I have a a video
selfie with you and I'll send it to my
boss and uh he never replies but let's
see what happens and within minutes the
boss replied and said the you know I
can't believe that you are with Ail on
this island I follow his work all the
time and you know I went to buy an Apple
Watch at the store just after a few
minutes that was the first time I went
after the pandemic and someone came to
me and said are you aob and so anyway
people do recognize and it had impact on
and and that's part of what the mission
that I I have as from practicing science
which I should say is extremely
important you have to practice science
in order to know what to Advocate there
are many science popularizes who do not
Practice Science and they are just like
commentators looking at a soccer match
and telling the players how to pass the
Bard okay and how dare they if they are
not playing soccer so my point is that
um aside from practicing science I I
enjoy communicating to the public
because you know it the inspires young
people uh how exciting science could be
and it shows that science should be
driven by evidence and we can talk more
about it but this was a result of the
first book extraterrestrial my uh new
book Interstellar came just a few months
ago and um just to mention two tidbits
from it um one I call the Hawking limit
uh and that is you know Stephen Hawking
was at the at my home back in 2016 for
Passover dinner and he could hardly move
a m muscle you know he he could only
move his eyebrows but nevertheless he
had a machine that could translate that
into words and uh you could still see
The Human Side of Stephen Hawking at one
of the events he said I'm
bored could we have could we go to the
hotel bar and uh have some fun and he
had an affair with his caretaker you
know some years before that so he was
definitely human uh but he couldn't
really use a will his physical body so
that's the limit that um artificial
intelligence works at right now without
robots you know uh CH GPT or anything
more futuristic uh could potentially
imitate mental states of humans and so I
call that the Hawking limit where it's
not associated with any physic physical
uh motion but actually just the mental
States uh are humanlike okay so that's
an
interesting uh limit where AI systems
will be quite um important in society
because you can develop a relationship
with them they would appear just like a
human except for the physical aspect uh
and then and of course for Interstellar
travel that's extremely uh important for
any probe to be uh to have a brain an
artificial brain so that the probe can
decide for itself how to respond to
circumstances because the time it takes
the signals to travel to the center um
is simply too long even for light it
takes thousands of years across the
Milky Way galaxy so that
AI uh brain is really essential for
interal travel the other thing I mention
in the book is classifying civilizations
and um to me a mark of intelligence is
the ability to um recreate your
environment so the most I mean we are uh
polluting our planet we are sort of like
these tourists that arrive at the
national park and throw bottles
everywhere you know like we don't care
so much about our environment as of now
maybe now we will start but uh the most
intelligent way is to actually recreate
the environment so for example create
create life in the laboratory um and we
are in principle a scientific
civilization can do that or even better
create a baby Universe if you understand
how to uh use quantum gravity H in the
lab and it's possible that the Big
Bang came to exist that way but uh
that's one benefit of finding the most
intelligent civilization in the Milky
Way because we can learn if these things
are possible we can ask them questions
my first question would be what was
there before the Big B okay that would
be my because it will teach us about
quantum gravity it will teach us about
our Cosmic Roots if they know the answer
that' be wonderful the second question
is um where is the nearest uh
Interstellar bar where you know
extraterrestrials come together and have
conversations you know because Steven
Weinberg the Nobel Laurette in his book
the first three minutes he argued at the
end that the more the universe is
comprehensible the uh the more pointless
it looks and the reason I think it
looked pointless to Steven Weinberg is
because he focused on Elementary
particles on things that have no life to
them uh and U we know from our personal
experience that finding a partner gives
a meaning to your existence so uh if we
ever find a partner out there on an
exoplanet or in between Stars uh it
could give a meaning to our existence
the universe will not appear to be
pointless anymore uh and the you know we
could learn from that partner and you
know this is my romantic version or
Reason uh to find the partner I do think
that it will help us yeah I think the
existential loneliness and the aspects
of of uh feeling like we lack Free Will
and and uh also the ultimate questions
this is what makes as humans and I I
want to point out to my to my viewers
and actually to my channel members at
YouTube uh you can watch a video I made
a video about you a uh not about your uh
research but your work with vosi I
believe it was on uh falsifying
inflation using the cosmic graviton
background that comes out tomorrow
morning uh unless you are a channel
member which I love and appreciate we've
got dozens and dozens of them and then
you can watch it basically
now I'll let you know thank you so much
I should tell you that I have a
follow-up paper I'm working on right now
and so you have a little scoop here that
wow if um I mean we tend to assume that
the Universe was
always the same in all directions that
it was expanding the same rate and
that's called the isotropy that the
Universe was always isotropic but if you
allow a small level of um uh an isotropy
of the universe expanding in One
Direction a little uh faster than in the
other direction turns out that uh early
on the difference was larger actually
and we just found the solutions for that
and what happens is along one axis the
short axis you can actually get to a
singularity before the other so the
other axis can actually expand at the
time that the short axis collapses they
can bounce and um so you can get a
graviton background with different
properties than you expect in an
isotropic universe and uh so you know
that's the fun of doing a uh science
that you never know what you might
discover tomorrow and actually the
reason I went to Washington DC is
because um I had an insight about
something that could be useful to people
over there but that's completely
completely unrel it's related to gravity
but not to uh anything we discussed so
far uh we need to get into uh the the
meat of subject matter today which has
to do with the claimed I will call it
the back reaction to the discovery of
spheral of likely extrasolar composition
in the Pacific Ocean site of the Cenas
2014 bolide so first of all let's give a
quick recap because I know you've got a
limited amount of time I want to be
respectful uh we have a lot to cover uh
can you summarize of the steps if you
will that led you to believe that the
boli discovered and uh with samples
collected from Papua nug guini that that
was likely to be of extra solar origin
right so this was the Fireball from the
object that was roughly the size of a
watermelon was observed by US Government
satellites on January 8th 2014 almost um
a decade ago and for five years nobody
paid attention but we calculated that
the speed of this object was so high
that it was Unbound to the Sun so it
came from interal space and moreover it
was moving faster than 95% of the Stars
near the sun uh at 60 km per second so
that gave us uh the inspiration to um go
out there to the Pacific Ocean and look
for the materials of this object so I
led an expedition and by the way it took
a year of very hard work to plan it to
receive the funding at one and a half
million dollars to have the best
engineers and uh Navigators involved uh
and eventually to design the Machinery
the tools to collect any molten droplets
from the surface of the object when it
exploded as a result of its friction on
air when it produced this Fireball which
carried about a few per of the Hiroshima
atomic bomb energy um and so we were
looking for millimeter sized particles
the size of a grain of sand uh at the
bottom of the ocean which was roughly a
mile deep at that location uh about um
60 miles from papuan nugini and um um
and the region that the Department of
Defense uh defined for the location of
the fireball was about seven miles large
so just think about it searching across
such a huge volume of water and looking
for millimeter size barus it sounds
hopeless a lot of people said you will
not find anything nevertheless we went
there uh and then we ended up finding
those molten droplets most of which are
background okay background particles
that are not related to the meteor but
we found an
enhancement uh along the meteor path so
we made the map and indeed found an
excess of spheral and moreover in that
region where the excess was we found a
composition of elements from the
periodic table that is distinct that was
never reported in the literature uh it
has rare elements enhanced by factors of
hundreds relative to the standard solar
composition and we had to give it a name
because nobody in the literature
described that before and we called it
Bellow composition because berum
lanthanum and uranium are enhanced
uranium by a factor of almost a thousand
relative to the standard solar
composition now you ask okay so what
does it mean uh we couldn't match it to
rocks on Earth Earth um we couldn't
match it to rocks on mars or um on the
moon or asteroids and we argued this
implies that it may be extra solar in
origin completely independently of the
evidence about the meteor speed being
Unbound um and um the question then is
what is the origin of this object and in
fact I wrote a scientific paper that was
submitted for publication that suggest a
natural origin that uh has to do with a
magma ocean planet a planet where the uh
Rock was molten actually the Earth was
in that state early on when it was
bombarded by heavy collisions and uh the
moon was made out of one of these
collisions and um and um just imagine
another planet with molten rock then
some elements are sync to the core of
the planet which is usually iron because
they have Affinity to iron leing behind
other elements and those elements Left
Behind are in the crust of the planet
and that's those are the elements we
found enhanced in the Bellow composition
so the suggestion was maybe
it's it originated from some exoplanet
that had molten rock um all across U the
the volume of the planet but then the
question is how do you kick it out of
that planetary system at a speed that is
faster than the speed of stars the
typical speed of stars and we came up
with a very interesting possibility that
you know the Earth uh when the the earth
when it's
close well we have the moon around it uh
so the moon raises tides in the oceans
okay we are all familiar with the tides
but if you were to replace the Moon by
the sun just put the sun next to the
Earth obviously the tides would be
stronger but not strong enough to
destroy the Earth by by Gravity by the
gravitational tide because the density
of the sun is lower than the density of
rock okay so it cannot destroy the Earth
if the Earth comes close to the Sun it
will be swallowed once it enters the Sun
but it will never be disrupted just by
the force of gravity however the most
common stars are 10 times lower in mass
than the sun they're called dwarf stars
and they are the most common and they
are 10 times smaller in size
so it ends they end up being a 100 times
denser than the Sun and they can destroy
the an earthlike planet that comes close
to them they will shred it into we call
it spaghettify the the planet make a
spaghetti like stream of rocks and some
half of the mass of that planet will be
ejected to interal space we calculated
the speed and amazingly it's 60
kilometers per second so so that could
be an origin for this meteor because you
expect the highest velocity fragments to
be kicked out at the highest speed uh
from the crust from the outer layer of
that planet of course there could be
also a an artificial origin we we don't
know for sure that it's natural uh and
you can imagine melting a computer
screen or melting um semiconductor and
obviously the abundance of rare elements
will be quite different from that of
common rocks so to find out the origin
uh we need to find bigger pieces of the
meteor and we are now starting to plan
the next expedition to to find those uh
the Machinery that we will use will be
bigger and more expensive uh but we are
hoping to do that in
2024 and um you know I'm always Guided
by evidence and I always claim that it's
a lot of hard work you know we spent two
weeks in the Pacific Ocean I didn't
sleep much during during those two weeks
because we had 26 runs where we lifted
you know a sled covered with magnets
from the ocean floor uh after it
attracted the magnetic particles these
ferals that we found and we would scrape
the magnets and put it back on the ocean
floor that was a lot of hard work and
the reason I bring this up is because a
lot of the
critics first of all they didn't do any
hard work they just Express an opinion
you know they don't have access to the
spheral they just say oh well maybe it's
co Ash that was the most recent thing
argument maybe it's co Ash well we
checked we have 60 elements okay from
the periodic table that we analyze and I
can tell you with confidence that it's
not coal ash the the critics were say
were looking at three elements out of
the 60 and saying oh well it looks not
so far but if you look at the 60 it's
clearly not call Ash we didn't find Co
Ash we found real spheral from a meteor
and we can talk about why critics behave
this way which is really not
professional I mean they attack on a
personal level and so forth but if I had
to summarize it in one word I would say
it's jealousy my thumbs rather occupied
right now holding up good old Carl Sean
but yours is free to push that like
button and don't forget to subscribe it
really helps us with the algorithm now
back to the episode jealousy so when I
look at the uh paper this is uh we we
should acknowledge again the mastadons
in the room Steve Dash Allen Jackson I'm
happy to talk to them you know when when
you and I hang up I'm happy to talk to
them anytime they're always welcome as
long as they adhere to the rules of
decorum and don't make ad hominum
attacks uh but they uh present a paper
last month I believe it was which is
called a critique of your paper I'm not
going to read read the whole title uh
but they go through 10 different uh
claims that would all have to be true in
order for your claim to withhold
scrutiny so I want to go through those
really quickly and you tell me just
agree or disagree um so first one you
agree with I'm sure the authors claimed
that the bide was Interstellar moving
too fast to have been bound in orbit
around the sun when it struck the Earth
agree right yes yes you assert that the
significant quantities of materials from
the bide would have survived inter at
spheric entry to be deposited on the SE
Flor mostly As millimeter siiz ablation
spheroids you already said that uh you
claim to know the position of where
these spals were deposited to within an
area 1 kilometer by 10 kilometers
long right the authors claim that a
statistically significant excess of
spals twice as many were collected along
the assumed path compared to two control
regions agree y authors measured iron
isup ratios in 11 spheral including
three Bellow spheral and find them to
lie along the terrestrial fragmentation
line with errors of less than 1% and
show frag fractional fractionations
consistent with iron loss by
vaporization during
entry right one of these spheral S21 was
found to be a compound spheral three
spheral stuck together while molten the
authors present back of the envelope
calculation consist this is also
consistent with Fireball
formation right authors measure the
chemical enrichments of the Bellow and
other elements uh and they assert that
this composition is not found in any
terrestrial sample and they claim bowo
is associated with the suum path of the
bolite absent from regions Far From the
Path and therefore not associated with
the Fireball the authors claim Bellow
compositions would be uniquely
consistent with formation in the magma
ocean of a differentiated extrasolar
planet now I don't agree with this one
so be careful agreeing to this do you
claim that they would be uniquely
consistent with formation in a magma
Ocean or wasn't that just one hypothesis
that's one possibility and that's why we
need bigger pieces uh I just wanted to
um give credit in terms of some of those
statements uh you know I've been working
part of our team U includes uh Dr Royal
Tagle he's the uh head of he's leading
the the work at the Brooker Corporation
in Berlin Germany for us he's using the
best x-ray Mass x-ray fluoresence uh
device that the world has to offer and
then my colleague at Harvard The
Professor Stein Jacobson who has a group
of postdocs working with him and uh
they're using one of the best mass
spectrometers in the world um to for the
analysis so very often you know the
critics are referring just to me but I
wanted to explicitly say that we are
talking about multiple people
contributing a lot of actually there are
tens of people on the paper and um
they include also a collaboration with
the University of Technology in Papua
nugini uh the head of the mining
engineering uh Department there Dr Jim
lamb uh is part of the analysis team so
there are lots of people involved for
some reason these critics prefer to
attack me but anyway they know about
these group I can oh wait I I just need
to mention why how do I know that they
because Steve Dash wrote emails personal
emails to Dr Jim lamb after I mentioned
him in one of my essays to Professor
Stein Jacobson trying to dissuade them
from being part of this scientific
research project and I ask you how is
that ethical how is that part of um how
should I say um constructive scientific
discourse he was basically harassing my
team members and telling them what
you're doing is wrong what you said is
wrong and you shouldn't do it he was
actively sending them emails now they
are senior people but he also sent
emails to Junior people student my
student my post
dog and he is a senior faculty
sending intimidating students and post
dogs I just wanted to bring this up
because this is completely inappropriate
and very aggressive behavior that has
nothing to do with science it's the
question whether you should intimidate
young scholars who are part of a
research team examining materials to
which you have no access following a
project that took months to
prepare two weeks to collect the
materials and then months to analyze the
materials this is a lot of work and you
attack them through the direct emails to
them telling them not to do that and I
just wanted to bring this up because
this is not in the public domain but I
can tell you I have access to those
emails and I just
decided not to mud wrestle because I
will get dirty if I mud wrestle right
there is this approach of the eagle you
know that when there is a crow on the
back of the eagle that pecks at its neck
the eagle doesn't fight the crow off the
eagle Rises to Greater Heights where the
oxygen level is low enough for the crow
to drop off the back of the eagle this
is the approach that I'm trying to take
basically doing the science to the best
of my ability you know I may make
mistakes wrong inferences but that's
part of doing science yeah my no and my
point is okay you can disagree with me
but to attack young scholars personally
through direct emails to them threat
threatening them and intimidating them
this is bullying and this is
unacceptable but this is being done by
those critics that you just mentioned
well again I I don't like hearing that I
mean we all live under this fantasy that
scientist are somehow exalted
individuals with access to special
wisdom just because we have special
knowledge but in fact nothing could be
further from the truth I always say that
scientists are like children they have
these wonderful qualities of curiosity
of imagination of of wanting to explore
the world with Wonder but just like a
child they also are Petty they're
jealous they don't like other people's
toys unless they get to have better toys
and in fact they'll do nothing more to
get pleasure sometimes than take down
arrival now I'm not calling uh Dr Des
Professor Das a child I am inviting him
I'm I'm throwing an invitation out there
if you would like to refute that I
follow him on Twitter um my DMs are open
uh Professor so you're welcome and
you'll get a fair hearing a you can
attest to that I've been challenge you
as a friend here is my point the biggest
damage that forget about the spheral you
know that's not really important here
because what he's doing is sending a
message that you dare not deviate from
the beaten
path that he defines as the as the Dogma
because if you deviate I will
aggressively send you emails and tell
you what I think and why you shouldn't
do it okay and that is very damaging
because the next time that the same
postd doer student works on dark matter
or works on the beginning of the
universe those after going through a
traumatic experience of this type where
a senior person behaves this way those
young people will not dare anymore they
would worry about their job prospects
and that is very damaging for the nature
of innovation in science that's what
bothers me not so much the debate about
these particular items on one of uh
Steve Dash's most recent tweets he post
a a claim from uh somebody else's post
but he retweeted a claim about Jesus and
how Jesus uh was uh claimed that your
love for God was measured by your love
of your neighbor and even your enemy so
I wonder if if Professor Desh takes that
advice to heart anyway the invitation is
open I'll give him a fair hearing and I
will confront him with those as I've
confronted you with things I disagreed
with you about and that's what friends
do and that's what science is all about
anyway getting back to his paper so he
says that none of these claims uh
withstand scrutiny not any one of those
t that I mentioned he go the first thing
he says is the the bide probably wasn't
Interstellar he says probably which is
kind of strange that he's claiming that
this claims that proves that your claims
are incorrect he says uncertainties and
the velocities of objects in the I'm
going to just put this up on the screen
because it's I know it's boring for
people that are just listening uh but
let me put this up on the screen there
it is okay you might not be able to see
this AI but you've probably seen it
before so I'm not goingon to okay the
aboli probably wasn't sphere
uncertainties and velocities are not
reported but these can be estimated
separately and they are large there's a
greater than 0.1% probability that it's
not Interstellar which sounds small but
a catalog of a thousand solar system
bids the odds are high that one okay so
that's just 0.1% converted to one in a
thousand appear to be Interstellar
velocities and that appears to be that
one the one 2014 what do you have to say
to that that you miscalculated the
enties or overestimated your answer this
is not me because the data was collected
by the US space command that the
organization that gets paid its annual
budget is bigger than that of NASA it's
supposed to advise the US president
about any ballistic missile that is
heading from North Korea towards the US
and suppose they were wrong by a factor
of three as Steve Dash and colleagues
argue in their velocity measurement they
would advise the president of Mexico
about a missile heading to Washington DC
I would be really worried writing a
scientific paper or posting this on the
archive claiming the government doesn't
really know what they're doing for a
budget of let me let me just streng his
point government has been known to make
mistakes right okay sure sure so that's
exactly right so I asked them in 2019 if
they can confirm the uncertainty in the
data so they went back for three years
analyzing the data and came back with a
letter to NASA stating that they are
confident that the
99.999% after looking back at the data
indeed this object was Interstellar so
you know I don't I I have no ability to
access classified data but they went out
of their way you know this is not their
day job to help the frontiers of science
they are supposed to protect the nation
against the National Security threats
nevertheless they took the time to do
that to write a letter to NASA and um
you know all I can say is that you know
when we analyze data in the scientific
literature we often have to trust The
Observers the experimentalists that
report about it so they reported about
it they are a
trustworthy uh organization that you
know could have gone back to the data
and looked at it and it's not just the
satellite data and by the way many of
the critics say oh we are talking about
groundbased data no it's not ground B
it's also satellite data and they
combine multiple sensors we don't have
access to it because many of the sensors
are classified but they went back
checked it and confirmed this is an
inter object that's my answer and it
just seems like it could be approach
from a basian framework that we teach
our you know freshmen right I mean what
is the false positive rate what is the
false negative rate and it's surprising
me for an expert in in you know in in
calculations of this sort that he's just
says you quotes vague things like
greater than 0.1% again extend an
invitation if you know him out there
please uh send him my way okay next one
he says that it none of it would have
survived entry if it were traveling at
the speeds reported and then at least
99.8% and probably greater than 69 would
have been vaporized in the atmosphere
leaving insignificant quantities to be
deposit that seems like it could be
addressed through a simulation he just
says it's great probably I I'm surprised
Again by the couching the the wiggle
words here why does he say probably what
do you react to that first of all the
number of spheros that we recovered from
the meteor path is fully consistent with
a tiny fraction of the material
surviving with the most of it being
evaporated in fact we wrote a scientific
paper that Dash was you know resisting
and pushing back against where we did a
very detailed model with an
undergraduate student that worked with
me for a summer and we posted it on the
archive where we calculate the size
distribution of the spheral what we
found is similar uh in the magnitude to
what we forecasted based on a detailed
physical model where we included the
evaporation of material the size
distribution that you expect solving the
energy momentum friction equations for
those fragments that may form based on
all that is known in the scientific
literature so we actually did the the
the hard work of a few months writing a
scientific paper on we couldn't do
better than that except go to the place
and look for any speros and so we did
the calculation it's a small fraction of
the total mass and yes what we found is
consistent with that okay so the next
one that he claims back
is or they claim I should say Jackson
and uh and um Dash the location of the
bid path is far more uncertain than you
realize and it's almost certainly
miscalculated the Cenas database reports
two locations for the Fireball and
they're 55 kilometers apart if we pick
one location there's still large
inherent uncertainties uh sound waves
trying to pinpoint it using sound waves
90 kilometers away so that that seems
like it could have some uh validity what
is what is your response to that right
so the department of the fence provided
a region that was seven miles in size uh
and there were three flares in the
fireball separated by a tenth of a
second this object was moving at 40
kilometers per second so over a tenth of
a second it would move about 4
kilometers you know like a few miles and
uh if you have three flares obviously
the explosion was spread across a region
that was a you know of the order of
seven miles or so so that's why the
localization could not have been better
by the Department of Defense but we also
analyze data from a seismometer in Manus
and papuan nugini just to figure out uh
the distance of the explosion based on
the fact that the sound waves arrive
later than the light we see that in
Lightnings um you know the sound the
from the explosion uh you know the the
the Thunder that we hear uh arrives to
us uh later and we can tell the distance
of the lightning based on the delay and
that that's what we used um in figuring
out the path of the meteor but more
importantly we had 26 runs 26 back and
forth scans of the region and we tried
to spread it wide enough so that we were
not restrict restricting our attention
we went even 20 kilometers away from the
location of the meteor path in both
directions so we try to move away from
the meteor paath as well and and the map
that we made was based on
that okay so the next claim he makes
here the next point that he makes is uh
whoops let me close that okay uh getting
some reports that people can't see it
out there put a thumbs up if you're able
to see this conversation on YouTube
because uh claims that uh people aren't
able to see it so leave a thumbs up and
leave a thumbs up anyway and please do
subscribe to the channel as I said I'm
going to have another conversation with
AI Bas on avi's work tomorrow tomorrow
uh for the channel and that will be a
deep dive into the physics of inflation
so AI does it all it's not just it's not
only Interstellar meteorites by the way
you went to Great Links millions of
dollars and uh tens of people to get
your meteorite sample I can give a
meteorite sample to any of my guests who
happen to win it or my my audience
members who happen to subscribe at
bring.com so please do that okay next
one the specific iron ratios are a
Smoking Gun for the spheral or
originating in our solar system the fact
that all these samples lie within less
than 1% it's a weird symbol there by the
way of the terrestrial fractionation
line including bosals they measured
indicates a greater than four NES and a
half probability that all the spheral
including Bellow are from our solar
system what do you say to that this is
an important issue um we uh had very so
the preprint that they're referring to
just considered 10% of the ferals we
just posted the preliminary results now
we're going going through the 90% the
remaining 90% so the report about the
iron isotope ratio was really a very
preliminary report in one of the spheral
uh where and it's true that in principle
if you have different stars exploding in
different locations in the Milky Way
galaxy um you will end up with different
isotope ratio for iron because different
isotopes of iron originate from
different processes uh like type 1 a
supern
or AGB asymptotic giant Branch Stars uh
and we expect variations if this object
came from a far away and so it's still
what I would say on that is that what
was reported in the perip is very early
uh preliminary analysis of one of the
spheros and we are now engaged in the
full analysis so we will report whatever
we find you know when my colleague Stein
Jacobson comes back to me with results
we just report them uh and here again I
should mention um Dash is very proud of
claiming that he was pushing against our
paper and in one of the arguments
someone looked back at our map and said
oh actually the map does not represent
exactly the color bar next to it and
maybe they tweaked the colors and I went
I mean that map was produced by my
postto Laura dummin and I went to her
and said and she said well it would have
been so much more work for me to
actually tweak the colors um you know
that critic actually magnified the map
and tried to look for a different color
she said that would be so much I just
used an off-the-shelf uh program to plot
this map um and so it just shows you the
level of negativity that I've never
heard you know I had more than a
thousand scientific papers I've never
heard someone being motivated to use a
magnifying glass look at a plot and say
say oh you were fudging this because the
color scheme does not and you know it's
not me it's a post dog that came to my
group from Stanford extremely talented
brilliant she was using the best tools
that exist for plotting and this person
blames us so I'm just saying there is a
lot of negativity that you don't find in
the context of other studies and they're
putting
the you know you know as we say in in in
yish the higher you fly easier you are
to shoot at and I think the next but the
next one Avi uh I think this is an own
goal Professor Dash and Jackson uh so
you claim and I'm saying you uh
Professor Dash they claim that all of
these have to be true okay so I'm
showing it on the line to claim an
Interstellar origin for the spheral they
collected all the links in the chain of
logic above would have to withstand
scrutiny and he says none of them do
okay but now this claim is that the uh
is that one of the spheral
is a compound uh spheral three spheral
stuck together while molten that's your
claim AI with your team and you present
a back of the envelope calculations is
consistent with the formation of
Fireball just speaking logically uh
Professor Dash this is uh a total
logical fallacy an own goal the triple
spheral even if the triple spheral are
not it doesn't mean that the entire
claim is wrong I don't know how he could
make that assumption it's like saying
you know if you don't have a Bernie
Sanders sticker on your car you can't
claim you're a Bernie Sanders supporter
if this is true or false it doesn't it
doesn't either refute or uh or neglect
the uh the base hypothesis correct so in
other words even if let's say he's right
here on his point number six he says the
Tripes spheral S21 almost certainly did
not form in a fireball event let's say
he's right okay which you obviously
don't think he's right but let's say he
was right in that case uh that spheral
is not a compound spheral does that mean
that the other ones are not Interstellar
in origin I mean isn't that a logical
fallacy Obi I completely agree and what
this one was the biggest spheral that we
analyzed in that preprint and 1.3
millimeters in size and we looked at it
first and it showed this bellower
composition and then we found it in
other spheral that do not look like it
so um we're talking about a class of
spheral that has a composition by the
way you know it's really analysis that
requires a huge amount of effort to get
to those measurements um so um I mean if
you just look at the scientific
literature on ferals U you would see
that nobody uh analyzed the you know so
many spheral at the level that we do we
have actually 750 of them it's a factor
of 10 more than the number of spheral in
a typical paper on meteor sites you know
and um we go a factor of 10 more we we
brought them from the bottom of the
Pacific Ocean you know it's a huge
effort and just read ridiculing it and
bullying people who engage in that you
know after such a heroic effort I think
what I would say to that is people who
try to
terrorize practicing
scientists will not get their way you
know we will continue the scientific
work irrespective of how many emails
Steve Dash sends to members of my team
because they know the truth they know
what we are doing and they know the
level of scientific uh Integrity that we
are investing in this the next one he
says despite your assertions the bowo
patterns have been seen before in Cosmic
spheral of solar system origin from the
Indian Ocean again would this if true
you always have to ask yourself this
question as a scientist if this is true
would this invalidate the base
hypothesis your hypothesis the prior
hypothesis that these are
extraterrestrial in origin so he's
admitting that they could be um that
these things have been seen before in uh
but only in our solar system that
doesn't invalidate that they could
originate from other objects in the
Solar system and they're not even
dissimilar to anthropogenic coal ash I
assume he covers that in more depth in
the paper uh I'm not sure why that's
relevant I can tell you the K Ash claim
was made by someone who wrote a research
note which is basically an unrefereed
two pager saying oh I found a paper in
the literature where if I look at three
elements they seem to roughly match the
element abundances that were in the bow
feros that's that's the claim on three
elements comparing them sort of
qualitatively and that's it he has some
tick marks and it's a research note that
is a couple of pages long not refereed
and then Steve Dash hangs his head on
that and to that I say you know you
should be smart in fighting the right
battles you know that's the uh because
if you were to be very aggressive on a
wrong statement you know it just shows
you uh your vulnerability you know it
exposes
your weakness which is basically to look
for anything negative to say and on this
you know we compared 60 elements and I
have it you know we didn't post it yet
because it will be part of the next
paper but we clearly see that it's not
collash he doesn't have access to the
materials and he makes this very strong
statement went out to the Press there
were a number of reporters who mentioned
it you know the one thing that reporters
do not realiz is that in science it's
not about it's not like politics where
oh someone says something therefore I
should present both opinions it's not
like that because if one side invested
months of work to do the hard scientific
work and the other side was sitting on
his you know chair and and and and was
just expressing an opinion and saying oh
maybe it's collash it's not a matter of
giving equally opportunity to both sides
right you need to put some weight on the
amount of effort and and those people
that have access to the materials
obviously they can examine the materials
we have that data that's the basic point
that science is driven by data not by
opinion and as much as Steve Dash you
know does not like the fact that we are
doing science we will continue to do the
science of course and I I view you as an
irrepressible force of nature the last
one has some um you know kind of ring of
authenticity to me as a question I want
to ask you because I'm not an expert but
now going back to U my meteorite which
again can be yours if you uh join my if
you win the giveaway that I have in my
less I'll send you one for free I
promising you of me uh but here's a
meteorite here that uh I collected the
hard way I went to Amazon and bought no
I I get them from a special dealer I get
them from a special dealer they're
they're Prime they're Prime um but this
uh particular sample uh you is the
fragment of the Campa Dello event the
explosion of a bowy about 7,000 years
ago in Argentina found about uh uh in
the 1500s uh the outside of this you
know kind of has these nods at some of
it has thumb prints on bigger sections
of it but I imagine if I if I cut it
open if I fragmented it um they would
look different inside in that the
exterior this part of it was exposed to
the harsh inter Interstellar uh weather
of cosmic rays and that induces what's
called spalation I want you to explain
spalation in a minute but wouldn't the
skin depth to spalation preclude the
interior of this meteorite or the boli
that you saw wouldn't that be make it
harder for cosmic rays to spalet and
then make the balao material or am I
getting this wrong I I think of it in
terms of skin depth penetration let me
start from um clarification the Bellow
composition originated from The Source
not from the travel through Interstellar
space sorry he's wrong then he says he
says that the abundance in these spheral
so he claims that you claim the high
abundance was produced by spalation of
atoms in meteoroids by Cosmic gamma rays
is indicative of cosmic gamma IR
radiation during its passage to
Interstellar so he's wrong you don't
assume yeah and and and by the way I I
mentioned to you this paper that I wrote
where I explain it in terms of um you
know a differentiated planet where
molten lava or magma ocean which he
actually mentioned in the previous point
you know that was responsible for the
separation of elements and maintaining
those Bellow compositions in the crust
that was then ejected through the
disruption of the planet so all of that
argues that it's at the source you know
the Bellow composition is from The
Source has nothing to do with the travel
through interal space uh and uh with
respect to spalation this is just a
simple process where you have energetic
particles uh for example cosmic rays
protons that are moving at a speed very
close to the speed of light and they
collide with a nucleus and breaking it
up uh and in fact there are some
elements like berium uh which are
enhanced as a result of energetic
particles colliding uh with with the
material um and like and and breaking it
up you know a heavier nucleus and uh we
do see enhancement of berum but that
could happen at the source it doesn't
have to be from spalation so the other
context that he puts into it uh would
any of it survive entry he does a backof
the envelope calculation and says it was
about the mass of half a
giraffe okay that's an interesting Mass
measurement 450 kg and therefore it's
only 48 CM sphere and diameter
equivalent um now if it's going at 140
times the speed of sound he says and
Jackson uh the meteoroid would have
completely vaporize in the atmosphere
yeah that's the calculation we did with
the
uh summer intern Emory teing hust uh and
you can look at that paper and we did
the calculation so indeed as I said most
of it is vaporized but we went through
you know the equations that describe
what what's left from that and that
would depend on the material strength so
if you assume a rock you get one answer
and we derive that in the paper if you
assume that it's made of stainless steel
uh the way that the Voyager spacecraft
was or any some you know artificial
alloy that is related to a an alien
spacecraft you know then the answer
would be different so we know that this
object by the way exploded in the lower
atmosphere and must have had a very high
material strength to survive down to
there and the it was tougher than on
meteorites so actually with a student
that approached me at a conference in
Stanford two weeks ago um that was a
student of material science that he's
doing a uh a PhD in Material Science and
he was inspired by my talk about the
Expedition so he came to me and said how
can I help and I said well you have a
computer code to calculate material
strength given a composition of material
and so let's simulate what this meteor
was made of and uh and and see if indeed
it was of very high material strength so
we're doing this and to that I say again
that when you deal with uh innovation in
science it inspires young people they
come to me and want to work with me h
two of my post dogs Laura domini and
Richard clet they they told me that when
I called them to offer them the
post-doctoral fellowship you know that
was the thing that they hoped for their
entire career before that because they
had no opportunity to work on these
subjects so these people these young
schol are inspired by Innovation but
then
comes an arrogant senior person and
tries to intimidate them and that's what
I find inappropriate good okay AI I know
you've only got about 10 minutes before
your next uh appointment um so we have a
couple of questions and from the
audience and we'll take some somewhere
about Academia we could take some of
those if you like somewhere about Israel
uh we can take some of those if you like
um so the uh well the first thing I want
to I want to get your reaction to is is
um there have been some reactions online
about the implausibility of statements
made by David grush and and others that
there's crashed alien spacecraft and and
and so forth and and the the argument
seems to go along these lines and I want
to get your reaction logically to them
one of them is that these aliens are so
sophisticated they can make a spacecraft
that can travel Interstellar distances
but then they crash on
Earth um I want to point out I'm a pilot
I fly little SES around okay I'm not
like um my past guest uh you know you
know when I when I had on haard Lee or I
had on Ryan Graves and these are great
Heroes these are military fighter pilots
of the highest order I'm nothing like
that but I'll point out that if you look
at the faa's accident database where do
you think the most
outlying probability is for a crash of a
commercial pilot piloted plane not an
amateur like me a commercially trained
pilot
somebody flying in which of the phases
of flight takeoff Cruise flight or
Landing which are the most likely to
cause an accident what would you say AI
probably Landing Landing it's like six
to eight times more uh perilous in other
words these accidents tend to occur
during the landing phase so I I like to
point that out to people that Snicker
and sneer including people like Brian
Green who I had on last week on the
podcast so I I did a wonderful interview
with him in person at Colombia uh right
before there was a a huge protest
against Israel but but at any rate there
uh so I just like to point that out even
human Pilots crash more during Landing
so and Military Pilots as well so anyway
I I think that's kind of a ridiculous
argument also it depends how many things
are flying you know if there are lots of
them then the chance even a small chance
would lead to some evidence over Decades
of time and you know it's it's all about
evidence you know people try to have an
opinion that's a very easy thing the
difficult part is collecting the
evidence if the Govern government has so
do you want my opinion on on grush
actually I wrote last night when I
returned at 10 p.m. from Washington DC I
wrote an essay with the title and you
can find it on medium.com with the title
of new physics or misinformation you
know that is the Dilemma that we face
when listening to the testimony of grash
in front of the House of Representatives
now you know it's completely plausible
that he is sincere that he just reports
what heard from 40 people who told him
about things that happened and then he
exaggerated the significance of those
and misinterpreted some and as a result
I mean he didn't witness it himself he
didn't see the materials yet he claimed
that there are there are there is
material in biologics of in Crash sites
and you know as a scientist I must say
that this is not convincing I need to
see the evidence if the government has
this
I really want to to nobody to see it
that's part of the Schumer Amendment the
UAP disclosure act if there is something
to it but there is another possibility
that um there is a campaign of
misinformation that some people want the
public to believe in things that are not
real and we know that in politics you
could have an agenda of that nature just
to mislead the adversarial countries or
to um make the public distrust anything
they here so that if there are programs
to develop new technologies that the US
government is funding through the
military-industrial complex H you know
that it will be lost in the noise if
someone sees something they will not
talk about it because of the stigma
associated with very Advanced
Technologies perhaps coming extr
terrestrially so that could be in the
background now this schummer amendment
is being resisted by some people uh in
Congress and the fundamental question is
whether the this resistance is
superficial they just do it for
political reasons I mean even though it
was proposed by the Senate Majority
Leader Chuck Schumer it was bipartisan
there was support for it in the Senate
but it's also possible that there are
people who know what the government has
uh they deal with highly classified
information and they know that there is
nothing uh to substantiate Russia's
claims so they go to the chairs of those
subcommittees and tell them look you
know this would endanger National
Security if there will be a committee
that will oversee what the government
does and ask for all the information
some of it may leak to our adversaries
and this is not good for the country so
so then there would be opposition but
you will not really understand why there
is this opposition of course there are
people who claim there is a conspiracy
the government is trying to hide I
personally I tend to believe the
government is incompetent to hide
something of that nature for so long
especially especially if it involves
biological materials yeah it would be a
conspiracy you know that would dwarf the
Kennedy assassination conspiracy okay I
have to ask you this question it's from
a listener on on YouTube hervig iRig de
wild so he's asking he's saying
basically we don't even know if what he
grabbed off the bottom of the sea is
anything to do with a bowy yet you Obi
are jumping to alien technology is that
what you're saying is this alien
technology claiming it I'm not claiming
it I'm saying it's a possibility now let
me explain where I'm coming from you
know just like you Brian I worked early
on on cosmology where for example we
don't know what the dark matter is
that's the 83% of the matter in the
universe we have never witnessed it in
the solar system so in that culture that
I worked on for decades people were
proposing different types of dark matter
it could be primordial black holes it
could be a very light particle like the
Axion it could be massive particles like
quickly interacting massive particles uh
it could be all kinds of things things
and when you were to propose
observational signatures of a hypothesis
everyone would cheer because it allows
experimentalists to pursue and rule out
possibilities so it's a an integral part
of doing science to propose
possibilities so that we can rule them
out and figure out the truth eventually
because one of them might be true so
what the way I approach this subject is
if I see an object a meteor that was
moving faster than 95% of the stars that
had material strength tougher than on
meteorites I say we should leave on the
table the possibility that it is a
voyager like meteor if Voyager were to
collide with a planet like the Earth it
would burn up in the atmosphere of that
planet as a very tough object because
it's made of an artificial alloy and it
would move faster than usual because it
was propelled by a chemical rocket so
that's all I'm saying let's leave it on
the table then the public gets extremely
excited and then some reporters report
about it as if I'm saying that and and
then my colleagues are arguing that I'm
saying that but I never said that listen
to my podcast interviews see what I
write on medium.com and you will never
see that as me arguing that it must be
an alien spacecraft I'm just saying this
is the possibility we should leave on
the table just like in the case of dark
mattera you would never dismiss weekly
interacting massive particles as a
possibility because you don't know the
answer okay uh we have one question from
friend of the show Ross at Event Horizon
he want to know who were you meeting
with yesterday in Washington DC oh there
were a number of people um some of them
were in Congress some of them were in
the Senate what I should say and some of
them were in the Department of Defense
what I should say is um I was amazed
like come at least two of these
meetings these are high level officials
okay they would come to me and say I I I
follow what you do and I I really admire
your work and I never imagin that I will
meet with you now I could never imagine
that they would say that because these
are people you know within uh at high
level you know within the US government
that uh so apparently they do appreciate
the Innovation that I'm pursuing and uh
I never take it for granted because you
know overall I'm just driven by
curiosity that's that's all that
motivates me I'm just a curious farm boy
trying to figure out the world given the
opportunity to be a scientist so that
you know I can answer questions myself I
don't need to listen to grash telling me
what lies outside the solar system
really I mean grash when he expressed
himself as as if what he's talking about
is a result of extra Dimensions or the
holographic principle you know this
didn't sound pro I I know these ideas in
the context of string theory we have no
experimental clue to support them uh
they're completely speculative unrelated
to any phenomena at low energies low
SpaceTime curvature that we have near
Earth so that sounded like far-fetched
to me uh but you know I I I just believe
that evidence will guide us to the
answer and we should collect it rather
than say it's an extraordinary claim and
therefore since there is no evidence we
should just shy away from it which is
pretty much what all the critics are
saying I say you know we need to seek
the evidence so extraordinary evidence
requires extra
effort it's a lot of hard work and that
should be celebrated the hard work of
science where we don't know the answer
in advance we don't have an opinion we
just work on collecting the evidence so
what I feel is that instead of that
being celebrated within Academia you
know the hard work I see people like
Dash ridiculing it pushing back however
within government people are supportive
you know at every I always receive
positive feedback within the public
people are extremely supportive so once
again we come back to where we started
something is wrong in Academia yeah
indeed we do and I guess the question I
have for you is uh where do where do you
go from here and both the uh search for
these these materials Origins first and
foremost and then where where where do
you go in Academia is there is there a
home is there a a place for ideas uh
that can survive the kind of onslaught
that we've witnessed in the last two
months it's just it's just been
absolutely shocking some people are
saying oh the donors just have to and I
was I was asked by you know people well
what if the Jewish donors just sto
donating I found that very insulting
it's a it's a it's a it's a very
offensive Trope that Jews are mainly
interested in how their money is used
and if if we don't have a a a happy
State of Affairs than the Jewish banking
bankers and the uh and the pro Elders of
Zion we'll just cancel let me explain
one very simple fact I was at Harvard
University for 30 years okay 30 years
Claudine gay came to Harvard University
eight years ago okay she doesn't own
Harvard
University even though she's the
president I feel that this is my home
and if someone comes to my home and
violates my principles I don't leave
home because of that I will try to
change the intellectual climate we live
in for the better okay that's my answer
but with respect to the future of um uh
the the
meteor research uh we are planning an
expedition it will probably cost um uh a
few at least twice or three times the
previous cost probably around four to
five millionar because we need a much
more sophisticated equipment to find
bigger fragments of the object and you
know once we find them we can easily
tell the difference between
a rock and an artificial technological
Gadget because a gadget could have
buttons on it and I actually asked
students in my class whether um if we
find Gadget whether we should press any
button on it and half of them
said please don't because it will affect
all of us half of them said yes please
do because it might be chat GPT 100 and
then one student asked me what would you
do Professor L and I said I will bring
it to a laboratory and examine it no
worries and actually after we examine it
I promised Paula Antonelli in the spirit
of love the aliens to put it on exhibit
at the Museum of Modern Art because for
us it will be Modern Art to just witness
that very good AI well this has been a
treat but I I really salute you for your
courage and and also just the
intellectual uh striving for truth that
I always associate with you and you've
got millions of fans around the world
you're always always welcome here on the
podcast we're overdue for a dinner
together for a lunch for whatever we can
arrange uh hopefully on the uh on the
East Coast or the West Coast maybe
you'll come out here in the winter and
uh you'll you'll get away from it all in
southern thank you so much and if I
could just mention uh my Mantra is
maintain your childhood curiosity and
never pretend to be the adult in the
room that's the first um thing that I
advise young people but the second is
you know let's let's work together
rather than hate each other you know
that it's the source of all the problems
we discussed starting from the Middle
East going through what happens on
campuses and ending up with scientific
discourse let's just be positive rather
than negative and um this will solve all
of these problems yes I agree science is
our greatest hope or possibly our
greatest source of uh probability for
demise I I hope we'll choose the wise
path obob we have your website uh
dlob
l.m medium.com it's on the screen and uh
AI thank you so much stay safe over
there I worry about your safety on
campus to be honest with you no worries
I my skin is now made of titanium after
I survived the attacks by DH not Bellow
it should be made of bow you should have
a Bellow
suit yeah all right lro lro Shalom AI
thank you